bonjour à nos d'âge alors le cortège
doit se diriger vers le sacré coeur
cannes et l'ambiance actuellement week
ou tenir en se rapprochant de la place
de la bastide sont un peu plus d'une
centaine de gilet jaune réunir pour ce
nouveau samedi de mobilisation des
gilets jaunes qui restent déterminés à
se faire entendre
ça fait maintenant 3 et qu'ils
manifestent chaque samedi quasiment pour
demander plus de justice fiscale sociale
et environnementale avec être thématique
assez importante hausse du pouvoir
d'achat et la mise en place du riq du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne alors
assez gilet jaune aujourd'hui ils sont
venus rendre un hommage particulier au
pape le colombien on c'est un crack en
colombie est le théâtre depuis une
dizaine de jours de violentes
manifestations et que les affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre
24 morts alors vous entendez peut-être
dernière - de gilet jaune qui les
bienvenus elle est policier on a un gros
dispositif de police
aujourd'hui pour se rassembler puis des
agents de la brave aussi qu'ils soient
mobilisés à quelques rues du cyprès
intervenir au cas où je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants rien n'a
changé au contraire s'empire les plans
sociaux et un ces chiffres il faut que
le peuple se réveille et que les
politiques de gauche de droite
il nous emmène dans le mur nous les mois
je suis content
la modélisation et j'espère vivre dans
un monde meilleur et pour vivre dans un
monde meilleur il faut descendre dans la
rue et nous c'est qu'on fait depuis
bientôt trois ans à saly versé au mois
de novembre
on manifeste tous les samedis qu'on a
toujours autant de sdf la loi chômage
qui vient de passer
on ne manque pas la vie des gens il ya
de plus en plus de gens qui meurent de
faim moi je fais une distribution de
bande solidaire précaire on reçoit des
colis alimentaires pour dix de plus en
plus et je vais au resto du coeur je
fais je suis bénévole aux restos du
coeur donc je vois la précarité et la
pauvreté et c'est pour ça que je suis là
et je me bats pour mes enfants
moi j'ai travaillé toute ma vie j'ai
recommencé de l'âge de 14 ans j'ai fini
à 62 ans j'ai même pas 1000 euros de
retraite
vous l'avez entendu un gilet jaune
eh bien tu y as reste déterminée à faire
entendre leurs revendications mais qui
estime qu'ils seront présents si le
porter jusqu'aux prochaines élections
présidentielles et bien pour se faire
entendre
les gouvernements et des manier de
matran particulier merci pour toutes ces
précisions